[Music]
in Konya news do now submitted by fried
potatoes you bug is stupid hash browns
aren't fried hell are you talking about
oh I see all my bad David told myself I
missed you I'm so glad you're back below
Kanye says he was used and vows he is
done with politics I'm a sick [ __ ] I
like a quick [ __ ] sick [ __ ] I like a
quick [ __ ] used what hell is that me
hired his sneaker sales ain't going so
good that's what I heard
no for real though yeah the Yi's man
it's not going so good I heard that it
lately has taken a hit
so he's like yo I'm good hey or just
might be the fact that he's [ __ ]
waverunners are a little I miss that
told Dad shoot been going on like that
we missed a debt you know I'm saying
it's like the people really get popular
hate that [ __ ] you guys coming back and
everyone's behind the wheel it's not
coming back are you out of your mind
dad shoes that people are said that
people are buying
I'm not even [ __ ] you my dad's back
in stock yeah all the shoes that's
really all the shoes outta whack back in
the day they're back now the same exact
tree box that I got my ass kicked for
they're actually popular now that's
crazy even like the sweaters and like
everything ugly from the pad it was
coming back now you're gonna tell me
that dudes are wearing kids I'll [ __ ]
leave why dude okay yeah
actually guys what are ways coming back
no it'll never come I just bought some
green corner I'm not stupid
Watson who who saw me where is are you
well like girls could wear anything and
it'll look kind of cool I mean as long
as this tight it's pretty good fitting
you're pretty much good yes always it
look like they're kind of in a horror
movie I'm in yeah and it made more sense
Kanye tweeted these tweets here oh he
tweeted these tweeted these tweets and
would you like to read them Steve I
would love to between anything else
besides sweets make it tweet uh gifts he
says my eyes are now wide open and I
realize I've been used to spread
messages I don't believe in
I am distancing myself from politics and
completely focuses on being creative I
introduced Candice Candice Owens to the
person who made the logo and they didn't
want their name in it so she used mine I
never wanted any association with blex
it I'll explain later
I have nothing to do with it I would
like to thank my family loved ones and
community for supporting my actual
beliefs and my vision for a better world
I support those who risked their lives
to serve and protect us and I support
holding people who misuse your power
accountable I believe in love and
compassion for people seeking asylum and
parents who are fighting to protect
their children from violence and war I
support creating jobs and opportunities
for people who need them the most
I support prison reform I support
common-sense gun laws that will make our
world safer
this was interesting because you know
when you read it out loud he actually
sounds like a beauty pageant queen
that's all politics today oh yeah yeah
yeah sort of the same say me beauty
pageant stuff yeah I believe I believe I
believe until it's not convenient yeah
right yep yes so kanye west that blacks
that thing he's talking about is Candice
Owens's thing about like let's get black
people out of being Democrats
that's like black exit who's Candace
owns like a commentator she's a
conservative commentator oh I just want
to put this out there his first tweet
though that's exactly what I said on
that last video we did on Kanye and I
haven't seen that video but people told
me that people were mad at me why are
they mad at you because when we're
talking about the Kanye thing I guess
cuz I got a bunch of DMS and they're
just like yo man they're mad at you
about the Kanye thing you know and I was
like what what did I say about Kanye and
basically what I said was that I don't
[ __ ] with Kanye anymore because he
doesn't realize like what he says can be
misinterpreted you know and so it
doesn't matter if you're intense good if
you keep on trying to do good things but
you keep [ __ ] it up so you should just
shut the [ __ ] up to be quiet you know
just for now and you should be mindful
about what you're doing this cuz like
he's such a huge influencer right that's
just something I'm saying be mindful of
you don't have to but people were mad
they're like oh you know Kanye is the
future you don't know you tell me Kanye
is doing great things but he just said
what I said you know I'm like what the
[ __ ] something your [ __ ] face you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] backpedaling
[ __ ] what are you gonna say now suck
my [ __ ] dick yep his shoes ain't
working out dude yeah it's true you know
I don't think he's walking back he
didn't walk back any specific ideas oh
no no I'm talking about the other people
Oh actually comments the fans that were
went in on David now they was just
saying the exact now they're on my side
oh yeah dude that's right I'm like I
said the same thing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
solenoid oh maybe I am on David's side
and then he's like oh man you just call
me a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
ball sucking [ __ ] yes the whole like
so Kanye commenting on the flexor thing
and saying like I'm distancing myself
away from you I said that was because
Candace Owens said that he that Kanye
West created the designs undercooked the
colors for flexing this merch here so
she was claiming that Kanye did this but
thank kinase like I introduced her to
the person that did this they didn't
want their anyone it so she threw my
name on there that's like the ugliest
line I've ever seen in my life that
looks like church retreat close dude
it also looks like The Blair Witch
Project poster legit when I went on
mission trips this is what we would have
my clown and his church of faith on the
bottom yeah it's a it's like you know we
need wall piece or something should be
under that yeah that's trash I think he
was more offended that they said that
was his stuff me Kanye West usually but
this is after two weeks from him
visiting Donald Trump read that
interview was a [ __ ] showed like
everyone has a screen like a video of
him opening his home and it's like zero
zero zero I feel was tight dude it was
good people did like a little visual to
Venice yeah they put a [ __ ] what's it
called like the Ray J Kanye [ __ ]
porno on there they opened it up the
Reagan Ray J Reggie and Kim yeah great
music I can't wait to be that age deeper
I just what a [ __ ] I do my kids
before things
the Internet's my old man doesn't [ __ ]
I'm like oh you want the lunch we said
what's on the Apple computers earlier oh
yeah so because of Kanye saying they
just didn't distancing himself from
politics and just completely focusing on
being creative everyone's like finally
yeah we miss Kanye we miss creative cars
this way about all [ __ ] artists and
politicians are not politicians but
artists and celebrities I'm like shut
the [ __ ] up and do your thing I don't
care I don't want to hear George Clooney
talk about taxes but then because we
know that they have such crazy influence
right like let's say there's a
politician that you're really for and
you're like damn like we need this
person in the White House fighting for
whomever you want and then now they get
together with George Clooney like
wouldn't you want George Clooney like
push the message [ __ ] no Oh George Judy
first of all okay
man yeah I don't feel like he's the best
holder of the torch you know really
politicians to say politicians actors
are whatever creative should Jesus speak
did you see that so there's like this
video I picture I think and I was like
oh we need their talk discussing like
the Syrian refugee crisis and all this
definitely today we have Gerard Butler
like why why does [ __ ] Leonidas need
to talk about this today to talk about
the Syrian refugee crisis Swift us no I
think they're for people that are like I
like celebrities and then they just like
the same thing with brand endorsements
too like proactive you know that makes
more sense if Diddy's like I had [ __ ]
pimple problems and it fixed me I'm like
because those aren't things that require
knowledge the stuff that requires deep
knowledge I want [ __ ] those geezers
now about us yeah people that come out
most people don't think like they're
just like oh yeah I don't follow
whatever George Clooney says yeah like
oh I'm on board that I hope they don't
but I know they do but I hope they don't
even like for example like like Jordan's
right the shoe if they're trying to sell
basketball shoes they put it on
basketball players I'm like that's cool
with that if straw rod blowers wearing
Jordans that's not gonna want to make me
buy more basketball shoes might though
because a lot of maybe that's more than
3-hundred it kick someone down a well in
the Jordan if I'm watching London as
Farnese wearing some sick seekers maybe
I'll go baby
but for me it's so like against common
sense when you bring people that have no
knowledge at all about it yeah I'm Chuck
Norris you should vote for this senator
I'm always like why aren't you kicking
him in the throat dude that's what I
want to see remembered that whole time
when there was like this huge huge
little Twitter thing where they're like
oh these new media influencers should
speak up about politics yeah the kid
that [ __ ] eats plato's talk about
politics the [ __ ] on out of here like
like whenever the last election was I
tweeted from the voting booth I was like
hey so I'm in the morning
I need some social media influencers to
tell me how to volcán I don't know what
I'm doing in here
can anyone with an audience between the
ages of 9 and 15 tell me how to [ __ ]
involved awesome yeah there's all the
Hannah Hart's and everybody's out there
going like you got to do this yeah you
have a position of power you should use
it like shut up
why is my drunk kitchen at the White
House Obama no offense to her by the way
she's a nice person
I'm just saying like when I see my drunk
kitchen shaking Obama's hand I'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening yes I agree
with that when they are pushing specific
agenda or whatever but I do like seeing
influencers just saying like hey go and
vote like your voice master that's fine
that's awesome but when the person the
person that fills up their car with
popcorn is really adamant about a
certain position I'm like all my [ __ ]
like you know just didn't like I like
that kid like what's his name let's say
for example that Roy wasabi kid right I
like that kid right but this folks are
just talking about politics I'm stalking
them in the face dan drops its gonna
tell me who to vote for like I'm gonna
be I'm the guy who reviews like burgers
in his car maybe I'll be for that
actually yeah actually these chili
cheese fries are so friggin good and
also you got a vote for governor this
one guy I gotta tell you about him I'm
into that maybe maybe he's the only
person yeah
you
[Music]